hola bienvenidos se nos pide que
grafique mos la función igualados seno
de menos x en el intervalo cerrado de
menos 2 p2p así que como es el intervalo
cerrado estamos incluyendo los extremos
menos 22 pies están incluidos y para
hacer esto primero voy a graficar la
función y el seno de x la tradicional y
después de graficar esto pensar en cómo
en cómo cambia dado este 2 y el menos x
entonces primero hagamos e iguala seno
de x aquí está el eje horizontal el eje
de las equis y acá está el eje vertical
no olvidemos el eje de las yes y nos
vamos a enfocar en el intervalo cerrado
de menos 2 p2p así que aquí está menos 2
pib aquí está el punto menos pin
obviamente este punto es el 0 es el
centro es el 0 y aquí tenemos pi y acá
está el punto 2 pi
ajá entonces bueno ya con esto ya con
esto aquí tenemos claro no olvidemos el
eje vertical
aquí tenemos uno acá tenemos dos aquí
tenemos menos uno y por supuesto menos
dos ahora voy a copiar esto tal vez
usarlo para usarlo después entonces lo
usaré cuando ajuste esta gráfica y
entonces copio muy bien ahora pensemos
en la función seno de x qué sucede
cuando el ángulo x es igual a cero
cuando x es igual a 0 seno de 0 que es
es cero cierto en efecto ahora voy a
dibujar aquí un pequeño círculo unitario
para usarlo como referencia después
entonces porque es lo que yo hago cuando
cuando quiero averiguar la el valor de
alguna función trigonométricas esto es
lo que yo hago dibuja un círculo
unitario y entonces tiene radio 1
x se refiere al ángulo y cuando el
ángulo es 0 seno será la coordenada y
aquí entonces seno de 0 seno de 0 es
igual a 0 mientras se incrementa seno de
pi sobre 2 eso es igual a 1 senodep y
sobre 2 te llevará al valor 1 luego vas
a senodep y te llevará a 0 entonces seno
de pib te llevará a 0 y después seno de
tres pisos de 2 te llevará a menos 1
entonces luego seno de 2 nuevamente te
lleva a 0
y si los gráficos se mirarán algo así
estamos aquí entre 0 y 2 y se mira algo
así ahora mientras vamos en la dirección
negativa vayamos ahora con la dirección
negativa en seno de en seno de menos
piso de 2 ahí tenemos el valor igual a
menos 1 seno de menos pi sobre 2 es
igual a menos 1 y entonces regresamos
otra vez después a 0 y ahora en menos 3
piso sobre 2 eso es recorrer todo esto
ahí es igual a 1 luego en 2000 negativos
en 9 menos dos pies nuevamente cero así
que la curva se mirará se va a mirar
algo así en la dirección negativa
ajá todo esto todo esto es consistente
con lo que sabemos de la función seno el
periodo de estreno de x aquí frente a la
frente a la x tenemos un coeficiente es
1 el periodo será 2 p sobre el valor
absoluto
uno es simplemente entonces dos pib o lo
puedes ver aquí el periodo de el periodo
será dos pi toma la longitud de dos para
que se repita todo el patrón ahora cuál
es la amplitud bueno estamos entre uno y
menos uno la diferencia total entre el
valor mínimo y el valor máximo es de dos
ajá entonces la mitad de eso es 1 otra
manera de pensar en esto sería bueno que
estamos variando uno desde el punto
medio y eso es eso es muy directo el
amplitud es simplemente 1 y ahora ya con
esto vamos a cambiar un poco ahora
ahora hay que graficar ye igual a 2 seno
de x entonces graphic hemos ya igualados
seno de x y aquí es donde voy a utilizar
la am la imagen que copie al inicio de
este vídeo así que aquí la pongo ahí
está súper bien
entonces qué pasará qué pasará ahora que
tenemos ese 2 ese 2 en la función ya
igualados seno de x que pasará como va a
cambiar la gráfica todo lo que hicimos
fue multiplicar esta función por 2
entonces a mars así que bueno cualquier
valor que tome simplemente será el doble
ahora tenemos que 2 x 0 es 0 2 por 1 es
2 y dos por cero es voy a hacer
cuidadosa aquí entonces 2 x 1 es 2 2 por
0 es cero
a todos por menos uno es menos 2 y 2 por
0 es nuevamente 0 se va a mirar algo así
la gráfica la gráfica entre 0 y 2 p
entonces entre 0 y 2 y se mirará algo
así y bueno claro podemos continuar en
la dirección negativa 2 x menos 1 es
menos 2 2 por 0 es 0 1 y 2 por 12
positivo 2 por 0 es 0 entonces en la
dirección negativa se mira algo así es
mejor intento de dibujar una curva suave
espero se entienda lo que vengo yo
diciendo y bueno así se va a mirar así
se mira y que acaba de pasar aquí vemos
que la diferencia entre el valor mínimo
y el valor máximo incrementa por un
factor de 2 entonces la diferencia total
es de 4 la mitad de su vez 2 así que
cuál es la amplitud de aquí exacto la
amplitud de aquí es exactamente 2 la
amplitud puedes visualizarla como el
valor absoluto de este número el 2 y el
valor absoluto de 2 estos así que de
hecho esto tiene sentido como un sentido
común porque bueno la amplitud de aquí
es 1 y ahora estamos estirando nos desde
la posición inicial el doble de
distancia estamos multiplicando por
y ahora regresando a la función seno de
x vamos a cambiarlo un poco graphic
hemos ahora la función seno de menos x
así que voy a poner acá los ejes y ahora
mi meta es es dibujar la función seno de
menos x entonces ya igual a c 9 menos x
y ya no tenemos yo no tenemos el 2 al
inicio vamos directo de seno de x a la
función seno de menos x entonces bueno
pensemos en los valores cuando cuando x
es igual a 0 aún será seno de 0 el cual
es simplemente 0 pero qué sucede cuando
x incrementa qué va a pasar cuando x es
igual a dios cuando x es igual a pin
medios el ángulo pi medios tendrá que
ser multiplicado por el signo negativo
cierto entonces cuando x es igual a pie
medio realmente estamos tomando seno de
menos pi medios y que es el seno de
menos medios bueno pues podemos ver acá
que es menos 1 después cuando x es igual
a pi entonces se nos estamos tomando
seno de menos pi ya vemos que es 0 y
cuando x es igual a tres medios estamos
tomando
el seno de menos tres y medios lo cual
es uno entonces aquí sería uno y una vez
más cuando x es igual a dos y será seno
de menos dos para lo cual es igual a
cero y puedes notar lo que está pasando
mientras intentó graficar la función
seno de menos x entre entre 0 y 2 para
esto es cómo graficar los puntos en la
dirección negativa cierto puedes
imaginar cómo tomar este lado negativo y
voltearlo reflejarlo para obtener lo que
tenemos acá de este lado parecer que eso
es lo que hace el menos x y usando la
misma lógica cuando vemos en la
dirección negativa por ejemplo si bueno
aquí si x es igual a menos y medios como
tienes el signo negativo enfrente será
senodep y medios así que eso es igual a
1 y entonces volteas esto sobre el eje
de la sien es esencialmente lo que
acabamos de hacer es como como reflejar
lo cierto lo acabo de decir
anteriormente lo reflejamos reflejamos
la gráfica del seno de x sobre el eje de
la siesta y se miran
se mira algo así entonces aquí sigo
dibujando esto se va a mirar algo así
qué te parece y bueno ya con todo esto
vamos a hacer lo que se nos pidió desde
el inicio entonces es momento de lo
bueno aquí la combinación vamos a
combinar el 2 y el menos equis y otra
vez entonces voy a necesitar el dibujo
de los ejes aquí está bien
y ahora hagamos lo que se nos pidió lo
haré en color azul aquí está aquí está
el eje y ahora vamos a graficar la
función ye igual a 2 por el seno de
menos x2 por el seno de menos x y
basándonos en todo lo que hemos hecho
como se mirará esto como será la
transformación si vamos desde la desde
nuestra función original de seno a la
función ye igual a 2 por el seno de
menos x como se va a ver esto ahora ya
con toda esta información hay dos formas
para pensar en esto tú podrías tomar la
función 2 seno de x aquí multiplicamos
la función por 2 para obtener el doble
de la amplitud y podrías pensar en
voltearla en reflejarla para obtener
menos x y si haces esto si haces eso de
reflejarla obtendrás y lo voltea si lo
reflejas sobre el eje de las yes es lo
que vas a obtener tendrás algo tendrás
algo así algo sí lo volteamos tendrás
algo así
parte desde este punto vamos a tomar
aquí desde 0 a 2 pib negativo después 0
después positivo y todo lo que hice fue
ir desde el bueno para ir desde 12 de x2
seno de menos x puede reflejar la sobre
el eje de las de las yes eso fue lo que
hice y lo mismo va a pasar entre lo que
hay lo que hay entre cero y menos dos pi
lo mismo va a suceder sólo debes ver
bueno qué valores tenemos entre 0 y 2
pib así que va a subir va a bajar y otra
vez pues subirán y por lo tanto es el
reflejo el reflejo de lo que había entre
0 y 2 pi
si lo observas bien es el reflejo y si
inicias con seno de menos xy vas hacia
20 x debes notar que sucede entre seno
de menos x2 seno de equis cuál es la
diferencia entre estas dos gráficas
cuáles bueno tenemos el doble de la
amplitud estamos multiplicando por 2 y
eso nos da obtener el doble de la
amplitud ahora la última pregunta que
tengo para ti es
como es el periodo de 20 x como es el
periodo como se relaciona con el periodo
de seno de x también es una muy buena
pregunta hay dos maneras de pensar en
esto y te dejaré pensar en esto por unos
segundos por bueno porque hay dos
maneras de pensar en esto podrías
enfocarte en las gráficas o pensar en la
fórmula lo cual me parece un poco más
intuitivo de la otra manera de ideas que
el periodo sencillamente será dos pib y
divides el valor absoluto del
coeficiente para saber qué tal que tan
más rápido llegarás a dos pib entonces
el valor absoluto del coeficiente menos
uno que multiplica a equis eso es
simplemente uno por lo tanto obtienes
dos bits eso es lo que obtienes obtiene
es exactamente el mismo periodo que en
la función seno de x interesante muy
interesante y lo puedes ver bueno
completas un ciclo cada dos pi un ciclo
cada dos pi entonces en todas las
gráficas lo puedes ver ahora
a cuál es la diferencia el periodo es el
mismo pero recuerda este menos x no
podemos ignorarlo no puede pasar
desapercibido pero bueno cambia el
periodo no no lo hace pero lo que sí
cambia es como se mira la gráfica ajá
entonces la gráfica cuando en cuando
empieza a incrementar las x en lugar de
seno ser positivo como lo sería en el
caso de la función seno tradicional aquí
mientras x crece estás tomando el seno
de menos x el ángulo negativo lo que
hace es hacer una reflexión sobre el eje
de las 'íes' estas son reflexiones y
estas dos son reflexiones ésta tiene el
doble de amplitud que ésta y ésta tiene
el doble de actitud que la otra